you
[Music]
the nation's jobless pictures looking
brighter the Labor Department reported
that unemployment dropped to 4.3 percent
in July a 16 year low if you're
wondering where the new jobs are coming
from look no further than your local
dining establishment jobs in the
restaurant industry are now growing
faster than healthcare manufacturing or
construction the trend is the topic of a
current article in the Atlantic and
we're joined by its author senior editor
Derek Thompson Derek good morning good
morning this is really interesting
because you point out that it's it's
happening all over the country in cities
like Cleveland even you say in New
Orleans a third of the job growth in
recent years has come from restaurants
that's right yeah I think this might be
one of the most underrated stories in
the economy right now you think you know
what are the scepters that have grown
the US economy in the last few years
it's it's we were manufacturing economy
and then we became retail than health
care but not restaurants are growing
faster than all of those in fact in
three years at current rates there will
be more employees in restaurants than in
manufacturing in factories that's why I
say in the piece restaurants are the new
factory is it as simple as we all have
to eat this is really off to eat there's
two things first we all have to eat but
we can't we have a choice we can eat at
home we can eat out of home right and in
the 1950s 25 percent of our food budget
went to restaurants today it's 50
percent so the share is doubled that's a
huge story the second thing though is
you look at factories they changed a lot
in last 50 years you look at retail the
way we shop has changed a lot in the
last 50 years how much these restaurants
changed almost not at all it's still
extremely labor-intensive going to the
restaurant in 2017 is basically the same
as going in 1947 you still need just as
many people in order to service that
diner that person eating the hamburger
and as a result more labor-intensive
industries have more labor right jobs
are jobs they're good but these jobs
don't actually pay as much do you know
they pay about half of the national
average and that's a problem you don't
want to have a high wage sector like
manufacturing essentially be replaced by
a low wage sector which is restaurants
but it's true jobs are jobs and a lot of
the jobs that our restaurant jobs tend
to be the kind of work the people move
through they start working at
restaurants they start working at
fast-food or or being
hostess or a host and then they move
into their you know white-collar
professional job later in the career was
there a specific point because we've
seen this growth over the past few years
but was there a specific point where we
saw it really start to take off yeah
it's definitely taken off in the last
thirty years just thirty years ago there
were three times as many manufacturing
jobs and restaurant jobs three times and
they're about to meet in two years now
that's partially the decline in
manufacturing jobs but it's also because
you've just seen this enormous run-up in
restaurant employment as people have
been more likely to eat out rather than
just yeah we're busier right now you can
have delivery is this despite this trend
Eric we've seen like 150 Applebee's and
IHOP stores are gonna be closing so what
does that tell us then yeah so the same
way that you have a hollowing out in the
middle of American income is you also
have a hollowing out in the middle of
American restaurants you have a lot of
growth at the bottom at fast-food you
have a lot of growth at the tops a
really nice fine-dining Hawaiian you
know Vietnamese like interesting new
places in New York and Austin and
Nashville but the middle family casual
you know your Applebee's you're IHOP's
they've really struggled recently as the
middle is moved to either end and that's
why you're seeing what you're saying
sustainable relatively sustainable we
still have to eat as you pointed out the
beginning in a segment we still have to
eat but at the same time it's possible
that some of these fast-food places are
going to experiment with the same kind
of automation that has hurt employment
in manufacturing we have to eat that we
don't want to cook that Thompson thanks